all right guys
bang bang i have a treat once again
dave is back uh the year in review is
out uh i have no clue how the hell you
write this every year but uh thanks for
coming on and talking about it
yeah it's always my pleasure uh we had
fun last time
it went for a long time too we have a
hard stop today so i think that's you
saying
dave don't run us into tuesday i i would
literally record with three or four
hours with you but
uh my fault that i have to move it
around a little bit today to record
uh let's just remind everyone who you
are
what you do at cornell and then what the
process is for you to write this year in
review
each year so i'm an organic chemist
um i started pondering i mean
my face was embedded in my career
you know 100 to the point i knew nothing
about what was going on in the world
till
uh somewhere around 95 i started getting
serious about markets
by 98 i started to get nervous about
markets so i i had gone into equity
i've been bonds till 87 went into
equities after the crash when a
colleague
i read about the crash i go what's that
about he said well you should go into
equities
despite that crash so i moved equities
after 87 and then
and then i got serious and i made a lot
of money being a tech bull
and thinking i was a genius and then i
and then i got nervous and 98 i started
liquidating by mid 99 i was out 100
out i went long cash and gold
and i've most of my gold i would say i
probably bought
um two years before the low so sort of
in the 270 to 290.
some more after that running it between
sort of 300 and
450 and then after that around 2015 it's
getting old now so it's getting harder
to remember but around 2015 i dropped
another wad on 1200 and so uh
so in any event i i turned into a bear
in the late 90s
and i really never recovered from that i
think it's very hard to be
a the guys who are unbelievably good are
the bear bowl combos and i don't know
how they do it because
i don't think the markets have ever been
seen since
since um i don't know the 80s i think
they were saying as hell
um and and so i'm i'm laboring over the
question of where do they go from here
and i i think i can make a hermetically
sealed case
that uh that we can't win from here okay
i don't think there's a mathematical way
to win from here
explain that well individuals can win
right so david tapper can
trade it up and trade it down truck and
miller guys like that but
the collective market i think is so far
overvalued
that um and someone has to own it so
to the extent that it regresses to the
mean and i i
created this graphic which i'm really
proud of showing how you regress to the
mean
and i gave a series of paths including a
precipitous drop to the mean
which would be a 50 or more correction
probably 60 percent would get us to
historical means
tread water takes 35 years at
assume normal gdp growth and uh
and and there's combinations of time
loss which is
time scares me more than price um and
and price loss and and you can make the
assumption we're going to stay above the
mean but then
your returns are going to stink because
you're not
buying a revenue stream at a credible
price
so your bonds are going to return you
zero negative actually right if you buy
bonds now
you can't make money you can trade them
if you're a bond trader
but if you're buy and hold you're going
to lose and and
60 40 portfolio therefore 40 is is
loser guaranteed loss in my opinion
um and the equities are you know 2x
60 uh a 120 percent overvalued ish
and so if they never collapse you're
still buying
a stream of revenue at twice the price
and therefore half the return and
and uh and so i i
i think the i the idea that you're
somehow going to get
even a 5 return i make the case using
some buffetology
and stuff that that even during good
times you make about four percent total
and uh so i i recently wrote about uh
inflation and of course it's like a
flame war on twitter because everyone
thinks they know what actual inflation
is
uh cpi targets uh or numbers are
anywhere between zero and two and a half
percent over the last uh
decade or so um then there's things like
the chapwood index that'll show
you know 10 to 12 percent uh and pretty
much a bunch of analysis
so that thing could drop fast yeah well
here's the thing is and then everything
in between
right so kind of i think that those as
the extremes it's kind of cpi is uh
probably under accounting
chapwood is uh if anything over counting
or accurate
and there's a whole bunch of stuff in
between how do you think about it and
really from the perspective of like
we see what the nominal returns on a lot
of these investments are but
the key being well what are the real
returns really depends on
what kind of inflation do you think that
we actually have regardless of what the
official numbers are
well there's what we have and what we're
going to get and then what we're going
to get is not here yet
of course what we have is somewhere
between those two i agree with you so
chap what is the inflation index by
getting
batowski yup ed batoski for chaplet
investments i think
um i was supposed to get introduced to
him i was hoping to because i wanted to
pick his brain but it didn't happen yet
um and and that's the inflation in
cities so one could argue that that's an
inflated estimate of inflation but i
think it's an honest one so i think if
you live in a major city the chapwood
index running
double digits for the last five years is
not a crazy number
i don't live in a city and therefore i
don't think my inflation numbers are
that high but if you live in san
francisco i you know i've got
former students living there and they're
paying four grand a month for an
apartment
that's got people sitting on the
sidewalks in front of it right i mean
it's just
it's as big as that room you're in yeah
right exactly
um so what's interesting to me about the
bad
i think the fed is lying i think they
must know they're lying
um i think they keep making stuff up to
justify what they're doing
so history so they're trying to make
sure history doesn't write a bad chapter
that we at least accept it i don't know
which
i've labored for 20 years whether the
fat or clueless or liars i just don't
i to this day i've asked famous people
you know are they clueless are they
liars and
and it's a coin toss no one seems to
really know but
but they're one of the two what do you
think
uh i it's hot greenspan once said if you
think we don't know what you can
see you're dreaming and that makes sense
to me so i gotta figure they're liars
and i i think they're and i think it was
um
ken rogoff's book i think it was in that
book
he said you know to inflate away debt
which
appears to be what their model is um
you can't inflate it away unless people
don't understand it's happening
once once they do then they correct for
it and then then you lose the effect so
it needs to be a covert
inflation so the lying would be
consistent with the idea we're going to
inflate away the debt and we're going to
convince
try to convince people that we're not
inflating away the debt so that the bond
market doesn't collapse and various bad
things happen
um it's going to produce a massive
problem if that's what they're trying to
do the other thing is
um the leverage in the system has simply
gone up
so they have yet to show me they know
how to inflate away debt
they know how to create inflation but
they're creating even more debt than the
inflation so i
i don't know what their plan is i don't
think they know what their plan is i
think they're hoping
so this is obviously a highly complex uh
manipulated system uh
there's lots of questions as to what
data to believe or not believe
is it maliciously inaccurate or is it
just inaccurate in some cases
what do you think i think that the
inflation levels
uh one on a geographic basis are
different obviously
two also socioeconomic status or kind of
buckets
experience different levels of inflation
for some reason everyone always just
uses those cpi numbers but
you know my favorite question to ask
people right now is what do you think
the difference is between the top 20
of americans uh inflation and the bottom
20 percent of americans in inflation
and so if you say to me hey the top 10
percent or top 20
get i don't know uh two percent
inflation right let's just say that it's
kind of one to two percent
uh and the bottom 20 is only having
three or four percent
i think you're full of [ __ ] right it's
just it's just
way much more um kind of egregious
on the extreme ends of the spectrum um
and so when you
do that what you start to understand is
like it then gets compounded by
was it bottom 45 of americans don't own
investable assets
so they're literally living paycheck to
paycheck they're just holding their
wealth in cash
and if they're also the people who have
the highest propensity to
uh experience higher levels of inflation
the you know think the goods and
services that they consume
like there's a really strong argument
that i don't know bottom 20 bottom 40
of americans have 10 plus percent
inflation right then you put them in
cities and you kind of like start
stacking this on the deck and you say
well
no wonder the wealth inequality gap is
just exploding in two different
directions right
with the cut higher than top 20 okay
i think the 20 percent cut off those
people are hurting too
okay what do you think if we go five so
i once created this thing called the
five percentile guy
and i i looked at what five percentile
meant in various categories the five
percentile guy is
is i mean at that point made 154 000 a
year
um he was or she was
there we go um uh uh
i had a net worth of 1.1 million even
though i had a chat with steven roach
who said no that's the total assets if
you take their house out it's more like
seven hundred thousand
which is a scary number and uh
and demographically they're boomers
right not to say there aren't some from
the other demographics but you get to
the top five percentile by patiently
investing and saving and doing whatever
and so
and getting promoted and so that tends
to be boomers
and then i did the analysis that okay so
let's assume top five percentile guys
about to retire what do they get
and if you assume they can take out four
percent a year
which is uh conservative money managers
would say don't do that now and they
they
they even would have said don't do that
in the olden days that you're you're you
could run out
but four percent it came out to
something like 48 000
a year now if you're earning 154 and
you're only taking off 48 000 you're in
trouble because you didn't learn how to
live on 48 thousand you learned how to
live on 154
000 and so even the american dream
was about to get squashed by the top
five percentile people
now there's you know there's social
security you can throw in their stuff
but i you know
it's it's really hard to dial it back i
think and so i think
you got to take out a chunk of money so
i think you have to have 25 multiples of
your annual salary to retire
that's mine one of the things that's
also interesting is i think we're now
at uh close to or at 50 of the us
government budget
um is uh or no i'm sorry i think it's
going to be 50
by the end of the 2020s we'll be
allocated to people over the age of 65
right through all of the different
government programs i think we're
somewhere close to like 40
at the moment um and so the belief is
that all of this is interconnected
right is basically you've got all this
manipulation going on there's all sorts
of
uh inflation or lack of returns uh
there's people who are having rising
costs of goods and services
and so what it does is it puts an even
bigger strain on the government
entitlement programs or government
support programs
uh those we know there's a bunch of
issues and so it's not only do the
issues they have are going to
persist but they're actually going to
accelerate and so does this all end in
like some big bang and like the whole
system blows up or
is there some other like pressure
release valve
uh in the system that we need to move
towards to kind of
maybe not solve the problem but just
like mitigate some of the damage that
you know people see on the horizon
well i think a year ago i would have
said i can't see the big bang theory
working
um not that i didn't think it could
happen but i couldn't see it i couldn't
intuit it
um now i can feel it so if you look at
this year you look at the amount of
money so like 25
of the dollars ever created were created
this year i mean that's a big number
right and that's that's a problem uh
corporate leverage which started out the
year catastrophically at a world record
is i think worse now do you agree with
that
that's that's my take on it if not worse
close to it for sure
yeah with businesses that suck right
some of them are good but
but the corporate world's just not in
great shape in my opinion and we're
we're floating on on a bed of air um
and so we've we've resolved nothing
we've added a huge amount of leverage to
the system
um i think what's being underestimated
is the number of
sort of we'll call middle class the
people who were you know paying their
mortgage paying their rent paying
they might have had some small grocery
or you know some small business the
the not the millionaire next door but
but
you know the 300 000 air next door
something like that
what we're what we're underestimating is
the fact that that guy probably
burned through all his money to stay
alive this year and so he probably still
has his grocery store but
he he mowed through his savings and
and and if that's the case i don't i
don't know what happened
right i think we knocked out nest eggs
this year that's why
we can't yet see the carnage yeah
one of the interesting things if you
kind of think you know just
uh in a generalized manner you basically
had 0809 let's say people who were in
their
late 30s to maybe early 50s they
essentially went through the financial
crisis many of them either got wiped out
or significantly impaired
they then start to rebuild whether it's
a savings
or you know a job or whatever but
they're overly conservative they've got
the pain
and kind of the the mental um you know
anguish from
that financial crisis and so really that
decades-long
equity bull run uh right before the
virus hits
uh they don't participate in the first i
don't know five six years
and then just when they start to kind of
loosen up and say okay look i you know
this time is different i'm going to
start investing again into 17 18 19 and
20.
uh they're buying at higher levels in
equity markets
and then you get the coronavirus and the
government lockdowns
uh and the data i've seen so far is like
most of the people who were selling
in march were the older demographics
because they don't have time on their
side and they don't know how long this
is going to last and so basically
you know the millennials are the ones
who are buying they're getting stimulus
checks they've got you know all the time
on their side sports are shut down this
is the new gambling you know all those
kind of narratives
but the older generation they're selling
their equities uh
because they don't want to have 50 less
they're okay with 25
less or 15 less and then all of a sudden
the market turns around and takes off
and they basically got shaken out of
equity positions that they would have
been better off holding
and so it's really interesting to kind
of see an entire generation
who really has gone through three
separate crisis right you got the equity
crisis you get the
uh the housing crisis and then you've
got kind of the coronavirus thing
they never had a long enough runway to
really build back
that nest egg and so i think you're
right in that like those people are in
really really bad situation right now
yeah
and um again we're so overvalued
if if if someone doesn't think we're
overvalued
you got to look harder because it's
preposterously overbelieved i
in 2019 i looked at 2018 i looked at 20
metrics evaluation
they all pointed to a 50 over valuation
and the market's gone up since then
about 35 percent
and gdp has grown about if you ignore
the covet beating
gdp has gone up around call it five
percent total
in those two years so so so that the
numerator has gone up 35 percent the
denominator has gone up a few percent
um making the valuations another
30 percent higher basically and let me
ask you this
that's that's that's a that's a red bull
you know die from space
when it finally happens i don't know how
it's going to happen i don't know what
to tell people i don't
i don't have a crystal ball but i think
it will happen
it's never failed i don't see a
mechanism by which it cannot happen
do you think valuations matter anymore
not right now not today but they will
and again so um
you know the triple q is priced now at a
p of about a hundred
now if you look it up you'll see numbers
in the 20s those turn out to be
fraudulent numbers
and you wonder how they committed the
fraud go look at horizon kinetics they
did a full analysis
triple q is a berkshire hathaway-like
unit
has the earnings to give it a p of about
a hundred so does the russell
um and so uh and so there's
just then there's what 14 to 18 zombies
in the s
p these are companies that can't pay the
interest rates on their loans with their
cash flow
and and and with interest rates at 5 000
year lows if you can't pay the interest
on your loans now
you have no buffer you you were and and
to calibrate you when interest rates
were
10 back in the 90s um
uh there were 2 zombies
and so when interest rates were by our
current standards oppressively high
people could all pay their their loans
and so that shows you the mess run
so no i if it stays up here it means
that you're gonna get
the p tells you you're getting one
percent right you just it's like
the analogy i use i always look for
metaphors if you buy a toyota
good car good solid toyota camry
for 300 000 bucks you're going to get
hurt in the trade-in
might be a good car but you can't pay i
went through the fangs this year
i'm stunned at the at the the valuations
of the fangs
these are the stocks that carried the
entire market for the last couple years
their their their valuations are garbage
their valuations are ridiculous i go
through every one of them and show how
much they could lose and
still not be overvalued and still not be
undervalued
what are the general numbers like 50 so
amazon went up 10 fold in six years
so if it gave back the entire game would
have a p
of netflix went up a hundred fold in 12
years
um if it gave back all hundredfold
meaning
one percent of its current price it
would still be losing money and would
lose access to the credit market so
here's a company that went up a hundred
fold and loses money
that that that that that's insane um
you know salesforce.com you know price
to cash flow is ridiculous gets put in
the dow they take out pfizer what kind
of insanity is that
salesforce.com is a bad joke compared to
pfizer exxon the ones they took out
um you know you got apple which has
obviously been a phenomenal investment
their their earnings and revenue has
been growing about
two and a half three percent a year for
the last few years
so if you're buying apple because you
think it's a growth stock you gotta
explain to me why
why three percent of your growth is good
news
and um it's it's highest valuations ever
amazon
even though i picked on it it's hard to
know where amazon's going to be
but um how
how many more doublings do they have
right
a lot of the exponential says amazon's
not going to become a 10 trillion dollar
stock
because it's still just retail and
they've almost clocked they've almost
taken out retail so i
you know what what do you think people
should do
like if you were talking to a son or
daughter
and they said dad this is
really bad i have no clue what to do
what's your advice to them
well as hot as this sounds my advices
would be to emphasize saving more than
investing so
get used to cutting money out of your
paycheck use your tax-exempt
aspects you know i i shelter about 30
percent of my paycheck
into tax exemption um forms
um i i actually tell them look
i think at some point the money you put
in now is going to get womped
do not worry about it when it happens
remember i told you it would happen just
go 60 40 just start get started
at some point you'll average it by the
way someone did a little math for me the
nikkei
obviously you know as i said they've
been
sitting on a donut cushion for 30 years
they're they're still the nikkei still
uh 60 recovered from its 89 high
people don't understand that that if
you're really in an overvalued situation
then it can take decades i i have a plot
that i've drawn two years in a row now
where you know the inflation-adjusted
capital gains on the dow
treads water for considerable periods of
time so from 1906 to 1986 i think it is
75 years 1906 to 1981
75 years the cap inflation adjusted
capital gains
did not move for 75
years now there were ups and downs and
the david pepper wrote the ups and downs
and generations are the ups and downs
but that's a long time to not make any
money
you got dividends from that but you also
have
taxes you have taxes on the inflated
return so nominal gains produce taxes
that are not fair
and uh and uh my brother's calling me
and um and and so that people don't
realize how long you can tread water
from over valuation from 1929 it was
just
eternity before you were even for the
last time not the first time
the last time and so uh
buffett's estimate of a a of predictable
returns
valuation aside he puts it at about four
percent
uh rob arnold puts it three point one
percent
i had it at four point five percent
before i read those two guys analyses or
paid attention to them and so
uh it's not six percent it's not seven
it's not fifteen
right those are not even remotely
sustainable so
so i think the boomers are in for the
rudest of awakenings
or the meanest of regressions as they
say
so before we move on to uh some
non-financial stuff
uh bitcoin i know that you uh have a
whole bunch of views
um but are usually pretty realistic and
honest
uh what's your thought there given the
uh the recent price rise and then
kind of overlaid with uh with all the
nonsense going on the traditional market
well you know i the the huddler
podcasters like to have me on
um i'm a bit of a target for them
because
because i'm i'm a guy they think ought
to like bitcoin
um i also don't pick on you guys for
owning bitcoin
uh this year obviously was a good year
for you it also was a good year to the
extent that it appeared to become
somewhat normalized by big investors
getting in so
so you know use going you joined up and
said that was a sign yusuko was going to
go to bitcoin but then this year's a
whole bunch of
big money guys um i will reiterate my
concerns about bitcoin
i think that you at some point will come
head to head with sovereign states
and at some point you either you'll
either be able to stay below the radar
of the sovereigns or you are going to
end up
in the battle of the bastards on on the
battlefield
and and i'm going to bet on the
sovereign states
i don't mind not owning it i would have
sold it if i bought it again i would
have sold it again
so i most would have traded it um i
would not have been able to hold it
through the run
you have to be you have to marry an
investment they always say don't marry
investment [ __ ] you have to marry an
investment you have the 100 baggers in
microsoft for people who believe no
matter what
the hundred baggers and mcdonald's just
i believe right
i'm not so yes i've been beaten up this
year but i'm not letting go
and so for me to go serious on bitcoin
i'd have to become a believer
and it's not the mechanics i don't get
it's it's the belief that you are going
to do battle with sovereign states
and um and i did a podcast last week and
a guy kept saying well i don't think
we're gonna but i he didn't give me a
reason why
i said well at some point they're going
to
they're going to make you either go
uncryptoed they're they're going to want
to tax you and they're not going to want
to give up
um their unique hold on currency right
they live and die by currency
you know dollar look at the battle over
the dollar reserve currency status
what's going on
i think bitcoin you know they talk about
sovereign kryptos we both know how
stupid that is the whole concept of a
sovereign crypto it's like saying a
jumbo shrimp right um
i think they're gonna want you to be
above board clean taxable
and then i'm not sure what it becomes at
that point but
i i could i can picture a path where you
guys do well i
i can picture the path but i miss a
picture path where bitcoin does a 100
percent
correction let me ask this question uh
is there a world where uh bitcoin ends
up becoming the solution for the
sovereignty
like i think literally sovereign
collapse
the the actual sovereign nation or just
the central bank slash currency of
the us dollar you know or other major
currency i think it requires a collapse
of the monetary system the bretton woods
system
i think it requires requires something
that even as a hodler you're not going
to want to go through
you'll be glad you have bitcoin right
that that i agree but it will be a
period of great
it'll be the dark ages sort of you know
and and so
that that will be the battlefield right
they're gonna they're they're not gonna
go down without a fight i think
and i've had hudler say no we don't have
to beat them they're not going to care
blah blah blah it's too broadly based i
point out that they knocked gold
out of the game and it not only was
central to our monetary system but it
was in the constitution they still took
it out
so i i'm i'm confident that when push
comes to shove they will fi
you know all the illegal stuff they did
in the bailouts this year right they'll
they there's no laws that they have to
follow so
so that's my bet um what i think is also
true is that the
the prominent famous huddlers now the
ones that you're going oh
i can see these guys doing this right
they're going oh my god
hedge from edger x just became a hodler
that's fantastic
right i don't think they're strong hands
i did a twitter poll and
and the poll suggested a lot of people
think they are but i i
i think they're traders i think these
are guys these are like the guys who
front ran the robin hooders and stuff
robin hodler's i call him um i think
these guys are in for the run i think
they did some window dressing this year
because they didn't want to look like
they didn't own it right you know the
drill
and uh but i think if bitcoin starts
having trouble these big hands are going
to leave as fast as they showed up and
in fact i was going to get into cannabis
with um
todd harrison and i had a couple of
hours on the phone with him i don't know
why it's not like he was uh it's
like he was selling it to deep pockets
here but um
eventually didn't go with it because
he's a derivatives trader
and the last thing i wanted to do was
own money in a fund
where the guy is hardwired
to run when the going gets tough right
that's his job to run
so i i can picture like getting beaten
up and then i'm saying okay we're
wrapping up the fun i got i don't want
you to wrap up the fund right now right
i've suffered
you know and so i didn't go with it for
that reason um
i think this this big money supposedly
entering bitcoin now
i don't think you know how strong the
hands are they could be strong but i
don't
one of the interesting things to me um
and i think directionally like
your thought process is exactly the way
that
i would think if i was a complete
skeptic
right like if i basically was saying hey
this is interesting i don't necessarily
believe but i also understand it well
enough to not
use arguments like uh it's worthless
nobody wants it
you know kind of the really basic stuff
so i think that you're you're directly
correct
in kind of the skeptical argument uh the
two things that
um i think are part of the conversation
and important to pull up
are one uh there is a
very large base about 60 of uh bitcoin
in the circulating supply
that hasn't moved in 12 months even with
all the volatility so they're not
institutions on most hands they're
usually retail and that
base is very very strong holders right
and when there is high
degrees of volatility like 400 people
uh it's more than 400 i think there's
like 4 500 wallets with 10 million
dollars of bitcoin or more so that's you
know single digit thousands
if you lower it down to like a million
dollar threshold it goes to tens of
thousands if you lower it even lower
you know you eventually get to um i
don't know
uh coinbase has got 35 million
registered accounts
so let's say that 50 of them are active
users
we'll find out when they go public but
um you know you're talking about
more than 10 million just in the united
states first
but if you take the top 40 percent of
the
the if you look at the largest 40
percent of the hardware's
it's a small number of people there's
some extraordinarily wealthy
guys at the top there and and i would
expect them to hang on
i i'm what i'm not convinced we'll hang
out are the hedges and
who this year announced they were buying
so those folks here's what's interesting
about them uh
people who are going and buying bitcoin
and just putting it into uh some sort of
cold storage they've got direct access
to it and they kind of have you know
possession
of the bitcoin if something bad happens
100
agree with you they're selling right the
one thing that is really interesting
though is
take something like uh gbtc right the uh
the publicly traded trust that holds
bitcoin
there's no redemption function of that
fund
and so once somebody gives them money
and gets issued new units or shares
that bitcoin can't come back out of
grayscale's hands
so what is likely to happen is there's a
premium today if something bad happened
it would actually trade at a discount to
nav but
that bitcoin is quote unquote being held
now it's not in the sense of
that's like your central fund of canada
is the precious metals
so they're similar to all the metals
they don't actually what they were doing
is they were buying metals and skimming
i didn't like that part of it they were
they were taking the premium and boiling
it down but the
the people who own the shares weren't
getting weren't getting
the medals yeah yeah so let's talk a
little bit about
uh the year in review uh one of the
things that you talked about that i
think
is uh going to be fascinating for people
to understand is this anatomy of riots
uh we saw all kinds of crazy stuff
happen we saw a virus we saw
government-mandated shutdowns we saw um
kind of uh
social unrest around social justice
issues uh and then we saw flat-out
riots how did you think about the riots
the social justice um you know kind of
protest
and uh acts of defiance um
in relationship to we're talking about
on the finance side the virus the
government made a shutdown
and kind of does that stuff persist is
that a thing that just happens during an
election year
and then it kind of dissipates like how
do you just think about that
well i think you're right on all counts
um
i didn't i did what i call the anatomy
of a
of the riots and and there's different
players and they serve different roles
and so you start out with the top shelf
of the guys who flat out think the
world's unfair and they should go out
and protest
and they they do so out of deep seated
conviction that they're right
um i think there's right below that
group indistinguishable from them or
what i call the virtue signalers who
want to go out
and show that they're virtuous virtue
signaling drives me nuts i'm pretty
pretty critical of that group i i think
you shouldn't be
showing your virtues that one but
underneath there
there's a whole bunch of other layers
one of which is the antifa guys who i
think are organized
and i don't think that i i i don't know
i don't have a good feel for where that
organization's come from but they got
money behind him um
i wrote about a guy who went to a bunch
of them and he kept seeing the same
faces at different cities
and so there was serious organization um
i think the crystal meth toting um
antifa guys are being paid to show up
and beat heads and smash windows and
stuff i think they're on someone's
payroll
uh i've increasingly become concerned
that china's running at all
and so um and that i'm when i say
increasing
it the last couple of weeks um things
have shown up on my
my computer screen that said holy [ __ ]
i'm underestimating china
like what well i i i just
did you see that uh we're gonna end up
an election fraud
fast um there was a video about election
fraud by
epic times and for about 45 minutes it
was the standard stuff of
video footage of ballots being dragged
out of closets and stuff like that
and testimony of people saying i i
watched them load a truck that i drove
from new york to pennsylvania
i think the case is pretty good for a
wholesale election fraud
um and and um
it traces beijing and i didn't know that
until
i know two or three weeks ago and then
this this this this documentary
going along showing what for me was kind
of review
and then it spins over to dominion which
is the voting boat county company and i
was familiar with that
and then they start saying okay who owns
dominion and all of a sudden it just
goes batshit
and and it says here's who owns the
million but here's who owns them
goes to ubs and one of the wings
goes to ubs beijing and we are
increasingly seeing connections between
between the election fraud and china
and and then they show this video of a
guy who is supposedly xi jinping's
right-hand man one of his key sort of
inner circle
giving a lecture to an auditorium full
of people
and the subtitle people say well how do
you know what the subtitle says like
there's a hundred people in my building
who could show that to be [ __ ]
they're not gonna try to fake subtitles
everyone speaks chinese you know every
other person here
um and he starts out he's this
personable guy he's talking the audience
and he says uh he says we've had control
of the upper echelon of u.s
politics for many years we've had total
control and
right away wow what did he just say
right i don't know why he's saying this
so rationally
and then he says then all of a sudden
trump gets elected we lost control
and he says we try to you know get money
into people to get him to to deal with
it he says if you
if you can't get get help you use a lot
of cash and people laugh he says and if
one watt does do we give him another lot
of cash
and he says that usually works he says
we couldn't do it
and then he gets to the end and he says
and now biden's going to be in the white
house and the whole audience laughs
and he says we're okay now and
i can't watch that video and not
not wonder hey why are they so brash and
do they really own our government at
this point do they really have control
and
do do stories of sort of obama's ties
with beijing and stuff are they real
um certainly i think the laptop and
biden i think
biden is going to be absolutely
worthless at dealing with china
he's going to be of zero he's going to
be destructive that's the biggest
problem i have with biden being
president
is i think that they do own them 100
and i think that therefore any progress
made towards evening up trade is
absolutely blown out of the water with
him in the white house i don't think
there's a prayer
let's talk about the election first
before we talk about kind of where we go
politically uh do you think that it was
election fraud
if so how and kind of like walk me
through your thought process of how you
even just evaluate
something that a year ago if we talked
about people would dismiss
as absolutely insane theory that uh
the elections are rigged that now all of
a sudden
is a very serious uh debate in our
country
between two political parties that seem
to be getting farther and farther apart
you know on a daily basis
well so i've been paying attention to
electric election fraud for
for many years probably 15 because i'm
always sniffing around dark corners
trying to find stuff that other people
are not spotting so
there were some wikileaks back in the
the
the mccain uh obama election there were
some wikileaks about
but crap going on in pennsylvania and
stuff and so i i always viewed it as uh
there used to be maybe they're not
anymore because youtube has become a
stalinist operation but um
there used to be videos people showing
here's how you hack
an election computer to get whatever
vote couch you want and this has been
these these youtubes were being posted
as as long as youtube has existed
so computer hackers have all claimed
that the election is is
absolutely perforated that anyone could
rig it if they wanted but
it always seemed like well probably the
two teams are just battling it's like
trying to capture the flag you know and
who cares
and and the bottom line is is that as
long as the two candidates were
both anointed
do they really care right and and the
answer was no until
trump [ __ ] him up and
i think trump caught him off guard i
think they thought they had control of
them and
and they didn't and so uh
so what happened so for four years the
dnc's hated trump with
every bone in their body the rnc to an
unknowable level has hated trump
right that's the thing we don't know is
that how many people in the rnc are
signing off with trump
saying look this is our guy whether we
like it or not how many detested and
clearly
there's a serious neocon group who's
never signed off on trump the never
trumpers at the highest level exists but
we don't know the percentage
i picked up something this year that was
very strange i wrote about the bailouts
i wrote about the corruption and i
i was scraping data about um
politicians families who got bailout
money
and i sort of rounded them up from
different sources i put them into one
bullet
and and i noticed the first thing i
noticed is they were republicans
i'm going well as a right-winger that's
not very good that's so embarrassing
um but i'm going but trump's
administration of course right
the second thing i noticed which was
surreal it may just be a coincidence but
they were all
they were all in um battleground states
it was michigan wisconsin georgia
florida arizona texas
and i go did they bribe republican
politicians
with bailout money to do something for
the election i and i
it's it's just an odd correlation just
one of those right now that's just my
spidey sense picking up something
that i don't yet understand um
so in any event so the entire left hates
them some percentage of the right that
we don't fully understand hates them
the entire media hates them including a
decent percentage i think of fox news i
don't think fox has ever been 100 from
you got tucker yes you got hannity yes
but you got a bunch of people who
really didn't seem to play the trump
card a lot
you got the average bloke who who has
been
brainwashed or been beaten down with the
mantra that trump is the second coming
of hitler
which allows you to have worker bees who
are saying i'm
doing this because this is for the good
and they might even consider doing
things that they wouldn't have
considered before because trump's evil
and once you you successfully tire him
with that brush then
honorable people do dishonorable things
right would you kill hitler if you could
of course you would right
well that's you demonize someone and
then you say now you got to do it um
so you got the intelligence right
there's no question the intelligence
guys are after trump
and and then you say okay they had four
years to prepare for the election they
tried to get him on impeachment
russia gave the whole thing they
couldn't bring them down did they
really forget to rig the election so i
used kind of the counter factual
argument i cannot
fathom that they didn't and i i've
watched looked at the data and i think
i think there's hell sell fraud i here's
here's where i feel guilty
in my interview i didn't talk much about
it but in the conclusion section i did
and i phrased it in a way that i regret
and that is i said i i you really you
can see i don't believe it but i made
some statement about i
wasn't enough to determine the election
i think i said something
i think i implied no and i regret that i
i
i think i was being dishonest actually i
think i was so punchy by the end
um and i'll sell for out on the limb
talk about all these dicey subjects that
um
that i i think i decided to protect
myself
and i i'm i'm this morning i was
thinking about writing a blog
on that topic and saying i i didn't
quite get that right
yeah what's so fascinating to me is uh
i've started the conversation with
people of forget this election for
example
uh or as an example just do you believe
that there has been
election fraud in the past and i'm it's
very hard pressed for
me to find people who say absolutely no
they get the count right
every single time to a t you know
literally
tens of millions of votes on either side
and they they nail it
um then i asked you know do you think
that there was a next
enough either inaccuracies or election
fraud in the past to
change elections harder to find people
who will uh who will agree with that i
think most people want to believe
uh sure they don't get it exactly right
they get it directionally right and
therefore
the outcome of the election is uh you
know what the
will of the people is or however you
want to describe it uh
but you could ask them why did they do
the fraud then if it never influenced
the election
well here's the part that uh i then ask
is i say
do you believe that there will be more
inaccuracies in fraud in the future or
less
and do you think that it has the
possibility of starting to affect
elections
and almost resoundingly the answers i've
gotten are yes so basically it happened
in the past it wasn't that bad it didn't
actually influence elections
uh but now that there's more political
divide there's more polarization more
extremism
uh it will likely continue and ramp up
from here and it may reach a point in
the future
that could change elections and so what
i say to myself is
they're probably directionally right
they just don't understand
how quick it can happen right like
happening quickly yeah
right on twitter and i called in some
favors from some heavy follower counters
and i got to about 18 20 000 votes just
to get a sample size up and i always
have you determine
what your view is and whether you lean
left or right i always get the
psychopaths and say i don't lean and i
go get
get a psychiatrist a psychiatrist you
need help
um and what i found was is that 66
of those who lean right thought that it
was unprecedented wholesale fraud and 37
of those who leaned left did and
i'm staggered i'm staggered that the the
numbers are actually that low
um i i can walk past this i can get past
this
but if they don't fix it for 2024
i i i don't know we're banana republic
at this point
yeah do you believe the uh hunter biden
laptop story or how do you think that
place 100
what is kind of your analysis in terms
of uh
one the story of like how they get
possession of the laptop and then to
the materials yeah the way they got it
was sanitized to be legal but i'm
guessing they got
it a better way than that although
although rogan
said you know someone said to rogan how
do you how did he leave it in the shop
and rogan said
he's a crackhead right you know that
does explain a lot
um i use that great graphic whereas you
know get hookers
call china and then says pick up laptop
the olympics is gonna put the pickup
laptop
um uh yeah i think there's a lot of very
prominent people who saw the evidence
and said yes i've seen it it's real some
very very high level people said it's
real
i also think it was not about the
election and that
i started asking why did they play it so
poorly they let out little bits of it
they showed some photos of hunter easy
to confirm
it's trivial to confirm actually just
take a couple of generic emails to
generic people and say did you get an
email from hunter biden on this day
if they did you could say therefore the
guy who gave me that date time
and email obviously has the other end of
that
that email chain and so i'm sure they
can confirm it
um the question is since they did it
poorly
as far as the election is concerned they
did it too late there were some like 40
million mailing
ballots already it looked like an
election dirty trick and so i said okay
i don't think it's about the election so
what's it about
i came up with four vested interests in
the laptop
um one is the other thing that i'm i've
written about before is
the two parties do not want to draw
blood
so they they want to inflict pain but
they don't want to draw
blood and because they know that if
there's a war they'll all get killed
it's like mob families right you say
okay
i i don't like what they did to us but
we're not starting to mob war over that
and so for example clinton pardoned 1100
truly despicable people if you and i i
went through the clinton parties they're
all bank fraud and drugs
they're just all bank fraud and drugs
which mean clinton got paid off 115
times
and it's a huge number of pardons for
president
the republicans picked on mark rich what
they didn't pick on was that hispanic
guy from guatemala or something who got
caught with 800 kilos of cocaine and he
got pardoned they didn't mention that
guy and a bunch of others and so it's
clear to me
clinton pardoned a bunch of bad people
for money and the republicans
did not call him on it and that's
that's the troublesome part and so um
and they've now made it very hard to
find the parts i've got links that show
the pardons but they're hard to find
they don't google easily now
um so what happened so either four
vested interests are the uh the rnc
has the laptop they could have thrown it
out there during the election maybe
hoping to have an effect but saying hey
joe we got your your son's laptop and if
you don't stay in line we're going to
destroy you
right that would be a vested interest
especially those who actually wanted
trump out of there
and wanted an insurance policy to make
sure that getting them out of there that
there was a way to handle the guy they
put in
by the way i go back to the iowa
caucuses
and and biden and harris were so
pathetic what do you think the pay
line was for a biden-harris
administration like a thousand to one
then we end up with them they were just
awful and and if you said those two are
going to end up running the country i go
no
no no not at the iowa caucuses they were
gone
she quit the next day zero delegates
right he looked like a
a post-it he was nothing
so they got inserted does he finish
the first term no as president no
no what happened well i don't know when
but they're gonna he's gonna get sick
they're gonna put her in
and that's my conclusion um i'll be
shocked to be mixing
um some people think he's not gonna make
it to inauguration i don't
i that would be stupid because that a
day after inauguration everything's
legal
a day before it's hard to say
what the rules are it could get pretty
dicey in courts
does does trump leave office uh yeah i
think so
um i think he's a patriot i think he's a
loon but i think he's a patriot
um so then the second group is the dnc
so dnc would like has a vested interest
in the laptop because they can say okay
joe now it's time to go
we want kamala in there for reasons i do
not understand because she seems so
vacuous and amoral to me
but that's just a first impression i
have to qualify that i have to give her
a chance but i'm not optimistic
um the third is trump family
so trump's leaving office they have the
laptop
rudy had the laptop so this is all
consistent i could imagine them using
the laptop
saying if you come after my family we'll
destroy you
right and i i could imagine that being a
risk for the family
and i could imagine them saying as long
as we have the laptop you can't touch us
do not release your goddamn doj on our
sorry asses
right and then the fourth group which
doesn't even need the laptop is china
because of the laptop's real china has
all the recordings all the videos
everything
there's no chance that hunter biden met
with anybody in china at any point
without video and audio surveillance on
him 100 percent of the time
which means they own the bidens
period and i'm despondent about that
because i do think the thing that trump
had right whether he played it right i
don't know is that we have to somehow be
able to compete with china
and i i think we've we've whatever
progress we
made um i think the
the biden win negates it all all of it
what does a kamala harris presidency
look like
oh it's scary i don't even know who runs
the country at that point
again everything i get is off the
internet right
and but that's why i like talking to you
because
because you understand that right it's
like look the information i'm getting is
the information i'm getting and here's
my conclusion based on that information
so i try to pick up shards and i try to
see where
self-consistency shows up it's a real
challenge actually you know
you get some lead like uh like the the
you know george floyd trying to
understand why he died you know there's
leading on i don't think that's a
piece of information value um
if i've read kamala harris correctly
she's
a an opportunist of a higher order which
describes everyone inside that beltway
um i don't think she's particularly good
at anything
i think she has less moral compass than
hillary
now i hate hillary because i think she's
a super
criminal but she's a super criminal
not unlike say the mob bosses who i
think have
principles i think they have dotted
lines i'm not sure harris has that i've
been
she really just looks like this kind of
i read a book on sociopathy and and she
looks like one of the chapters
to me they all sort of do in their own
way but um
trump is not a sociopath i think i think
you know people hate trump they think
he's so destructive for the country the
one thing i think
is true is he wanted to be great
it's his narcissist in him but i think
he wanted to be one
he wanted to be on mount rushmore and i
think he knew that to do that he had to
do things that were great
and patriotic and stuff like that so i
think i
anyone who can't see the merits and
things that trump did is
is just too narrow for me i mean i can
see the merits and obama i can i god i
can go back jimmy carter i'd have him
back in a heartbeat now you know
um if you think trump is nothing but bad
you've your mind is narrowed
yeah the one thing that seems to be
uh agreed upon both sides is that uh
there's an incredible level of
divisiveness uh and extremism
in american politics today does that
continue uh does that continue and then
there's a blow up and a third party
emerges like how do you see that playing
out i think you're thinking too locally
um did you see that world economic forum
90 second video of what the future is
going to bring
no i did not oh man remind me to send it
to you it's a 90
90 second short so you got this guy
klaus schwab
and christine regard talking about the
great reset try to get someone to tell
you what it is right the great resetting
and i'm trying to find people who might
know
i'm not even sure they know but this
90-second video
from the world economic forum
starts out by saying how good the future
is going to be and it says
you're not going to own anything and
you'll be happy about it
i'm going oh oh oh red flag first first
line and the thing red flag and then
they say
everything you need you will rent i'm
going okay from whom
right and it will be delivered by drone
which is their way of saying it'll be
cool
and then they show a heart being um
heart being synthesized by 3d printing
okay cool
and then they say you won't eat as much
meat
for the good of the planet it'll be a
treat you'll have an occasion i'm going
up
t-o-t-o you're not telling me what i'm
eating
and they talk about the us will not be
the dominant superpower now
i don't have a problem with that idea
because at some point we're kind of
looking like the roman empire
and so so i could imagine why people
going you know the the goss and the
ostrogoths and the and
the vandals and stuff are going we got
to get these guys out of here
i get that but to put on a video saying
that strikes me as that's that you know
you're saying we're coming to rome right
and that's a little problematic and uh
and it says and it it talks about how
that the world will be run by a
a group of countries and
and the whole thing is so creepy i said
to my wife who doesn't like to even talk
about this [ __ ]
and she said she was creeped for the
rest of the day
so if you haven't seen this world
economic forum um
i posted it on twitter this morning if
you want to go to see my twitter feed
one i said look i'm posting this again
it's the creepiest 90 second video i've
ever seen
and therefore i don't think second party
third party democrats republicans
is potentially relevant here i think
there's a much bigger story
and i've been talking with smart guys
from wall street
from from from plate this is not we're
not talking guys who are
who are living in their parents
basements um
who are now creeped out by this new
world order thinking
and and then the question is what's the
role of covid
what's the role of the lockdowns what's
the role of uh
of that war on cash what's there there's
all these things that are kind of
you know what's the role of china what
sort is russia collusion
a chinese psyop you know and
i've reached the point now where i think
it's possible that
that the world is way more screwed up
than i could have imagined and you know
i go outside the box pretty far
but i'm creeped out more than usual
so one of the things you talked about is
mine alteration
uh i've been talking about
desensitization to all the craziness the
chaos
uh is that intentional is it literally
just people are worn down they've been
sitting at home for the last eight nine
months they've just been bombarded with
one crazy thing after another from a
global pandemic to governments taking
people's individual
you know rights and liberties to
literally ufos now being confirmed to
whatever you know whatever ridiculous
thing you
you want to uh to bring up um is it just
literally the bombardment of constant
chaos and uncertainty
and ridiculousness that it's wearing on
people or is there some something else
that's kind of at play
um i it all could be part of the same
plot
if that's what you mean um at all so i
as you know a couple years ago probably
three years ago i said look i've had a
better paycheck
i think climate change is real i it sort
of was a vote
confidence in my brethren in the
sciences i said but i'm
i don't i've done the homework so i
don't know personally
and then two years ago i said um
i sort of amped it up a little bit and
then last year i dug deep and i said
is climate change real and when i i've
spent hundreds of hours
reading about climate change and reading
the stories about it who says what
and i got to the end of that pursuit
and i wrote about 25 pages on it i think
it's really good
um i think the whole climate crisis
story not the climate change but the
climate crisis story i
think is baloney i'm a denier i'm a
complete denier
explain the nuance between the
difference between the climate change
and the climate crisis story because i
think that nuance is really important
here
the the climate change story is
by definition climate changes um here
here's what i can tell i can give you a
synopsis of the
of the beginning of the problem first
you'll be told that no
credible scientists um doesn't believe
it
right that's the first that turns out to
be one of the big lies
because um what got me to think about it
is uh
people started beating on me and saying
dave you know people do don't believe it
and i thought it was a baloney and and i
you can run into nobel prize-winning
physicists all over the planet who are
saying
they're not just saying i'm not sure
what's happening they're saying this is
baloney
it's extreme famous famous physicists
that you know solar physicist is saying
it's all the sun has nothing to do with
any of this crap and then you find
cancer culture embedded in the debate
you find
censorship embedded in the debate you
find vast lies embedded in the debate
you find um this belief that
that it's so important that we have to
stay on the narrative at any cost
that's not science at all that's
propaganda
and then you find as soon as you start
looking at the numbers you go holy [ __ ]
you know they talk about big oil trying
to deny there's climate change like big
tobacco did i believe the big tobacco
did
but um big oil hasn't spent hardly
anything best i can tell they probably
support a few workshops and [ __ ] in the
think tanks but um
it turns out that um climate industrial
complex which is the general term i use
for
any any money spent having to do with
climate change whether it's departments
formed
whether it's government agencies whether
it's
carbon credits you name it um solar
panel companies it's a trillion dollar
your business
so if you somehow don't think that's a
conflict you're nuts you're
completely nuts and then i started
finding that all the claims weren't
holding
up so there is no evidence whatsoever
that we're getting an increase in
weather events from climate for a
hundred
goddamn years there's no evidence that
we've gotten in increased
climate events the sea rise is is
is rising the thickness of a dime every
year and it's been doing that for 10
000 years and you know the starving
polar bears right yes starving polar
bears well the polar bear population has
increased threefold since the 70s
if he's starving it's because there's
two god damn many
and uh and you just go on and on and on
and you just find lie after lie after
lie and after a while i go this
i'm done so i was not going to write
anything ever again
they had lost the scientists i'd written
what i was going to write and then
michael schellenberger published a book
and
michael moore did a movie and moore
started out looking at climate change
from the perspective of the guys
opposing it and discovered that the
conflict was
the climate changers so moore prepared
this movie and it was a compelling movie
and it started getting knocked off the
internet as fast as they could be posted
so now you have to go to bizarro sites
to find michael moore's movie
michael [ __ ] more right this is not
there's not some
some obscure guy there's a guy who ought
to be able to get it into the theaters
right
and it got knocked off youtube and so
it's it's one of those the narrative so
that there's the narrative on covet
there's a narrative on climate change
there's the narrative on shutdowns
there's
you name it every one of these
narratives
um are being shaped by silicon valley so
i've concluded that somewhere behind
silicon valley is a
very dark and sinister force and i think
uh
i was watching this guy eric weinstein
he thinks that jack
dorsey has been totally captured he
thinks jack
and i've always had this sense i think
jack is a sincere guy and he's lost
control of twitter
i don't think he controls what twitter
does who doesn't controls it
jack dorsey you think jack controls
twitter or jack does not control
no i think jack is now a puppet i i
don't think jack has control of his own
company anymore
okay who do you think controls it i
don't know probably um
probably um elliott management
the deep state if you want to call it
them the deep state i don't think
silicon valley is just
you could say all silicon valley is a
bunch of lefties i don't think that's it
i i think i think they are a bunch of
lefties but i think
i think i think it's being used to shape
our narrative just like cnn is totally
controlled just like msnbc is totally
controlled
this is what's frustrating you can't get
fact when the biden laptop story came
out which by the way
was a story forget about whether they
should be saying look here's why it's
not true here's why
they just denied it they just flat out
tonight every major knew
they they blocked it from being posted
on twitter they bought everything the
censorship was
unbelievable and so where
this is the part that's got me creeped
out i think we're heading for an
authoritarian state i never used to talk
that way i should think there was always
the risk
but if you don't keep reminding yourself
of of what it is that made us what we
are today
you'll lose it now jonah goldberg wrote
a book on this about
three years ago he said we've got to
teach each generation how we got here
and i i now realize that jonah was
screaming
at the top of his lungs what do you make
of uh
the non-tech or the non-silicon valley
tech world so
let's go to the extreme example uh in
recent days
uh everyone has been asking where's jack
ma like jack ma has just completely
disappeared no one's seen him for two
months i don't know that's probably
someone took him out
right so it's it's reminds me you know
when putin took out one of a couple of
those oligarchs right
it's just in the u.s i think we take
people out in other ways
but but they just rub them out right so
let's say that uh and again i want to be
clear here and i think you're saying the
same thing of like that's not what we
necessarily
uh are saying happened or uh have any
evidence of
right yeah it's just but the question's
being asked so let's just go through the
hypothetical situation of
um if that is true and that ends up
being
what happened uh jack ma is no longer
alive
uh regardless of the story of how we get
there what's the impact for
u.s china relationships financial
markets like
does that wake up people in america to
say wait a second like
we thought that was great technological
innovation
we should backtrack does that wake
people up and say u.s china relationship
should be different than it is today or
do people just say ah
there's another billionaire down the
street and let's keep living our lives
well it depends on our media
right and i i am so despondent about our
media
because they are the narrative shaper so
some guy came out
and said uh was denouncing conspiracy
theories and what a bunch of idiots
there and stuff like that
and they said they failed to understand
how complicated it is to set up a big
conspiracy and i go but it's not
it's trivial to set up a big conspiracy
all you have to do is control the
response to it
so they botch him badly and then they
just make sure that the media
never covers the botched part biden
right when he's when he's starting to
run when he's starting to get serious i
think they decided to try to put him in
the white house
um he had a lot of dirt in the closet
and
it was at two levels of dirt forget
about china which
was there too but he he had a lot of
videos of him
groping lives of senate senators and
visitors and stuff and
and there's people claim that look they
they had to stop
christmas parties this time because
biden was just groping wives the whole
way stuff like that
and so they um so they had this this
this this outpouring of
news stories about biden groping and
then they and then they
then they covered him as just the old
fondly old guy and he's really benign
and then
then they sanitized it what they never
touched was him
groping all the kids and he there you
know there's tons and tons of youtubes
of him groping
12 year old girls and you're going holy
[ __ ] grandpa
you can't do that and someone had to
tell him you can't do that
over and over he did it there's probably
30 minutes of compilations out there of
him groping kids
that never came out because that's too
yucky
and so um so the media is totally in
someone's pocket i just don't know whose
and and at one point i would have said
the dnc
um i'm now willing to entertain that it
goes all the way to beijing
i i just don't know at this point i'm
lost one of the
one of the craziest moments to me where
people always said trump is such an
outsider
and i was like ah kinda he's a rich dude
right he's from new york he knows all
these people
how much of an outsider is he uh but the
one moment where i
sat up and did a double take was uh in
the latest
coronavirus stimulus package they
basically had passed it it's going to
his desk to sign
and he uh like a frankly an absolute
savage got a press conference together
and stood up there
and just rattled off all the pork that
was in the bill
i mean literally you know a billion
dollars here a hundred million dollars
here the 50 million dollars to this
museum that's been closed this
whatever just going through it and
you're sitting there and i think it was
chamath palpatia who tweeted and said
if he had done this his entire election
and avoided all the crazy chaos stuff
he had had a second term because i think
unless the election was rigged
but fair the thing though was that when
he did that
i saw people from both parties online
saying whoa this is interesting
this right here where you have an
outsider who's basically
willing to take the political risk right
but in his case not necessarily risk
and expose this stuff i could get behind
that
and so what makes me wonder is like
weeks in office he said what's this with
a four billion dollar air force one
contract this is way over paying cancel
the contract
and boeing said wait wait wait till we
can drop the price right
so he started out doing that i think if
trump had not been running into
relentless walls you would have seen
more of that
when you are trying to deal with russian
dossiers and impeachments and stuff like
that
you don't have time to do stuff like
that although i think he
he still tried and i i i
he's so idiosyncratic to defend him
is problematic but um because
he's not normal by most metrics
but but but there were things i think he
wanted to be great i come back to that i
believe he wanted to be great
i want to finish up talking about uh
the idea of consuming content uh my wife
always talks about like
a content diet similar to a food diet
bad things in
bad things out uh very similar with
content
where do you when you wake up every
morning what do you go read
how do you seek out information that
maybe isn't so controlled in the
mainstream media
are there specific books or sites or
people you follow on twitter just like
when you think of the information you
consume
what is that well um
you know there's the bloggers that we
like
um and there's so many now that it's
that it's hard to
hard to keep up with any one blogger
religiously and so i sort of keep an eye
on twitter
um i get a lot of emails now people send
me stuff so i'm a bit of a
conduit where people send me stuff to
draw my attention to it
my email box has become a dumpster fire
because of that
um i i i'll confess i actually think the
best i gave me one site would be zero
hedge
now that's not to say that they get
everything right
but i they they're so edgy and they're
willing to go
so far into into darkness to look for
things
and i i have not detected
i've detected anti-establishment bias
that's
clear but but i've not detected
something where i got the feeling they
were molesting me
and and so i think they're getting stuff
wrong at times
of course just like we all do
um but you see stuff there that you
simply won't see anywhere else in that
people love to pick on xero hedge and i
go dude
give me another site any site i and i
did a poll one day on xero hedge would
you
would you rather get your information
from zero hedge of the media or
you know other and zero has got 92.2
and the chinese the chinese uh lab and
the virus story is a
i mean like literally quintessential
example of
i don't know necessarily if they're the
only ones who
thought it or looked into it right i i
don't want to go that far i don't know
what happened in other newsrooms or or
whatever
but they by far were the ones first
willing to
put it out there show the work
and so you know in a wild world i saw
i don't remember new york post or cnn or
wherever it was
uh but there was a um article recently
said the
senior level u.s intelligence officer
has confirmed to whatever publication
uh the most likely right not saying it
is the only but the most likely
explanation is that it leaked out of
this lab
and again people will debate is that
good is that bad
uh should they have stopped it should
they not what i don't care about all
that
it's just the fact that if that was a
story back
in march april
and people had it and they had facts but
it wasn't reported
that shows a bias just as much as
publishing it with an anti-establishment
bias right
given that i'm kind of
anti-establishment at this point i'm
okay with the anti-establishment bias
but i think
journalists are supposed to be
anti-establishment
at some level i think they're not
supposed to be kowtowing to the
establishment they're supposed to be
looking under rocks to find bad behavior
and they're not
so to me the constitution gave them
special privileges
and and with it came special
responsibilities and they've completely
and utterly thankful
the mainstream media is utterly failed
so trump's correct about that too the
media
is in some level now our enemy
it's not to say that we should wrap them
up because that then totally defeats the
purpose of having the media but
um i am a big fan of people who can
cross over the center line um
almost unexpectedly so the sort of the
two mirror images of that are tucker
carlson and bill maher
now mars not even a journalist but
tucker carlson is now tucker is very
right-wing
but when we were talking about going
into syria and doing [ __ ] tucker carlson
was hammering away at that and say don't
let him drag us into a syrian war this
is crazy parker was dead right
dead right and he by the way was the
first to post that goddamn
interview of the uh of the the
presentation of the guy
talking to the audience in china saying
we own the us government
we control the top echelon of the u.s
government that first showed up on
tucker carlson's show
and so so i like tucker i can ignore the
parts i disagree with
um i don't like anything on cnn because
i've never seen
anything on cnn that was remotely
unbiased she saw the gingrich
interview on cnn was that funny or what
did you see the gingrich one
i did not i'm only imagining what it
could possibly be
doing a cnn interview with two people
zooming
two women um and often he starts talking
about
george soros rigging elections
and uh and uh i find george soros to be
a bit of a garbage can where you dump
all the things you don't understand
into it i'm beginning to worry that
maybe i've underestimated the importance
of george but
but for a while i just said oh yeah
everything is we don't understand is
george soros's fault right now that
seems stupid
but he starts talking about soros and
you can watch one of the the women
she's sitting there and he mentions it
and she's sort of looking at the ground
and then he brings it up again and she
says
we're not going to go there and the
other woman chimes in she says yes we're
not going to go there what was
immediately obvious to anyone watching
and you go find this it's an
unbelievable footage
she had a producer in her head saying
dive dive dive get the [ __ ] out of that
story now
leave now right and so gingrich says
what
this verboden we can't talk about this
and they went to commercial
the next day they did a pathetic apology
but that was clear to me that that they
were not and this was
fox news i think and it was clear to me
that they were being told get
out of that discussion now
and i don't like that so
i don't trust fox news except for a few
key individuals any more than any other
and during the fraud discussions um you
say oh fox is back in trump no they
weren't
they weren't um they were taking a much
more centrist line
um and only a few of the extremists who
were sort of loyal soldier types
were backing it so i i don't like the
censorship i
i think it's a horrifying pattern that
we're seeing
we should all defy it the other thing
you should define
i say this my year in review but i'll
say it to anyone
stop being intimidated by the term
conspiracy stop being intimidated by the
term conspiracy theorists
these douchebags conspire they conspire
all the goddamn time please just say
you're right i am a conspiracy theorist
these [ __ ]
need our attention don't let that term
and stop saying
i'm not a conspiracy theorist but
because you goddamn are you just a
coward on top of it so please accept the
badge of honor it is our job
to theorize about conspiracies and i say
that
every year and i the most retweeted and
like tweet i ever put out there was a
tweet supporting the idea of owning up
to conspiracy theories
i am a conspiracy theorist i think
people of wealth and power conspire
and if anyone who doesn't think that get
psychiatric help because you are
a imbalanced person stop
being intimidated by that term when
someone tries to do it
smack them for me if you have to punch
them verbally aside
annihilate them do what you got to do
but don't let them push you back with
the term conspiracy
it pisses me off to no end they're
trying to shut down the conversation
own it say yes and you're a dick
that's the phrase i'm a conspirator and
you're a dick
i just put it to some guy i put it to
some guy yesterday who came out and said
had some bloviating thing about all your
stupid goddamn conspiracies he was like
blue check mark
and down the thread some guy posted his
linkedin
and he's from the world economic forum i
go
[ __ ] they just closed the loop
right so he's he's officially a
douchebag
all right before i let you go i got one
question uh we've got
eight sleep which is a smart mattress
this is their question
uh i sleep on it every night what do you
do for sleep do you sleep a lot or do
you not sleep at all
um i've been sleeping more because i
read a book on why we need sleep and it
convinced me that
um it convinced me that no one
can function on less sleep
now there's always people it's a badge
of honor that says
uh uh to work on less sleep i only sleep
four hours a night because i'm such a
macho man
turns out you're not functioning well
this book convinced me that you
might think you're functioning well but
you're not
and the book talked about all the
connections between not getting enough
sleep and disease states and all these
things and i finally realized
i'm not getting enough sleep so i i used
to just wake up and get up
and i now have taken to the habit of
waking up
doing what i got to do and then trying
to get some more going back to bed
and so i i sleep quite a bit now um
this is a mattress company i just bought
a mattress tempur-pedic it's a little
too stiff my back hurts
you shoulda should have gotten innate
sleep they got nice uh makes it nice and
cool
sleep deeper i i kind of thought
tempur-pedic well those memory
mattresses are great and this this one
isn't a memory foam mattress in my
opinion
it's missing the memory part so
all right uh where can we send people to
find you on the internet
um um at twitter at
davidb column um if someone's dying to
send me an email
if you're smart enough to get my email
address which requires using google
um i'm not going to give it to you i'm
going to require as a minimum
filter that you're smart enough to find
my email address which by the way is
subtly in my bio of my twitter feed um
then you can send me an email and i try
to respond to those
and uh where can people read the uh year
in review
say that where can they read the year
review my pinned
tweet um and if they're not on twitter
they can search
david david column year in review 2020
and that'll get them um and if they want
to
look at another year just put a new date
in that'll get whatever year
you want and this year i also included a
section called decadent review and i
pulled out all the sections that i wrote
for the last 10 years i thought were
timeless
and were were durable the ideas were
durable
and that that that you could read them
today and still get the
holy [ __ ] moment out of them like i
think uh i think i wrote the best thing
written out there right now at least on
the las vegas shootings
which were by the way totally bogus or
something dead wrong with that story and
i i lay that out pretty good
so about 20 links to the last 10 years
of
of articles that are that i think
have withstood the test of time and so
check for that i highly highly recommend
people go read it it's probably the best
thing written all year
every year so uh one thank you for
putting the time in to read it
to read all the information and to write
it but we will have to do this again my
friend
i i always enjoy it so thanks so much
for your time you betcha that was fun